Nos piden sumar y simplificar
la raíz principal de "2x" cuadrada,
más 4 por la raíz principal de 8,
más 3 por la raíz principal de "2x" cuadrada,
más la raíz principal de 8.
Hagamos estas pequeñas sumas,
de hecho,
podemos simplificar y luego sumar,
o también podemos sumar y luego simplificar,
se ve que podemos sumar primero,
así es que hagamos eso.
Aquí tenemos la raíz principal de "2x" cuadrada
y aquí tenemos tres veces la raíz principal de "2x" cuadrada,
estamos sumando un algo con tres veces ese algo.
Pongamos aquí el 1 para que nos quede claro,
entonces al sumar un algo, más tres veces ese algo,
nos da cuatro veces ese algo,
el resultado de esta suma,
es entonces,
cuatro veces la raíz cuadrada,
la raíz principal de 2x cuadrada.
Si esto te confunde un poco,
piensa que este término,
raíz principal de 2x cuadrada,
es una nueva variable,
llamémosle a esta variable "a".
Aquí aparece también esa variable "a",
estamos sumando una vez "a",
más tres veces "a·
lo cual nos da cuatro veces "a",
"a" es la raíz principal de "2x" cuadrada,
ya hemos sumado eso
y ahora vamos a sumar cuatro veces
la raíz principal de 8,
más una vez la raíz principal de 8,
y aquí la misma idea, tenemos cuatro de estas cosas
que estoy encerrando en magenta,
más una de estas cosas,
este uno es implícito,
así es que cuatro veces algo,
más una vez algo,
nos va a dar cinco veces algom
así que aquí tenemos,
más cinco veces la raíz cuadrada de 8...
más 5 veces la raíz cuadrada de 8,
4 raíz de "2x" cuadrada
más 5 raíz de 8
aquí tenemos,
cuatro veces algo,
más 5 veces de otro algo.
Estos términos no los podemos sumar,
sin embargo este término de aquí
sí lo podemos simplificar.
Sabemos que la raíz principal de "2x" cuadrada es,
déjame escribir aquí, primero el 4...
Entonces tenemos 4 por...
y la raíz de "2x" cuadrada
la podemos escribir como la raíz de 2,
por la raíz de "x" cuadrada.
Esto es este término de aquí...
y el siguiente término sería más 5,
la raíz cuadrada de 8
y 8 lo puedo escribir con el producto
de algo que es un cuadro perfecto
y otro algo que no es un cuadro perfecto
8 es igual a 4 por 2,
así que la raíz principal de 8,
la podemos escribir como la raíz principal de 4 por 2
y ésta a su vez la podemos escribir como
la raíz principal de 4,
por la raíz principal de 2,
y aquí
¿qué podemos simplificar?
Bueno,
sabemos que la raíz principal de "x" cuadrada,
es el valor de "x" positivo.
Estarías tentado a poner simplemente "x" pero no,
no es simplemente "x"
es el valor de x positivo,
lo cual lo escribimos
como el valor absoluto de "x"
¿y por qué esto es así?
bueno, ¿qué tal si "x" es negativa?
supongamos que x es -3,
cuando elevas -3 al cuadrado obtienes 9,
pero al tomar la raíz principal de 9,
obtendríamos 3 positivo,
no sería el valor original de "x"
el cual es -3
sería el valor de 3 positivo,
por lo cual hay que tomar el valor absoluto
y la otra cosa que es un cuadro perfecto aquí es 4,
sus raíces principal es 2
su raíz cuadrada principal es 2,
para ser más precisos
¿y ahora qué tenemos?
bueno,
si invierto el orden de los términos aquí,
aquí tenemos cuatro
por el valor absoluto de "x"
por la raíz cuadrada de 2,
deja de poner lo mejor en este mismo amarillo...
por la raíz cuadrada de 2
y esto le sumamos más,
5...
5 por 2,
5 por 2 = 10
este término de aquí es 2,
lo hemos reducido a 2
esto es 10 por la raíz cuadrada de 2,
ahora, podríamos decir
que aquí ya hemos terminado
o podríamos avanzar un poquito más
depende de cómo lo quieras ver.
Aquí tenemos cuatro veces
el valor absoluto de "x" de raíz de 2
y por acá tenemos 10 veces la raíz de 2 ,
aquí tenemos 4 veces el valor absoluto de "x",
por algo,
más 10 veces ese algo,
podemos sumarlos,
u otra manera ver esto es que puedes factorizar la raíz cuadrada de 2
de cualquier manera obtenemos
4 por el valor absoluto de "x"
más 10 que multiplica...
que multiplica a,
la raíz cuadrada principal de 2,
así que depende donde quieras llegar,
a este,
o a este resultado de aquí más simplificado
cualquiera de los dos resultados
funcionan bien.